uh I did have no I know I know this but
yeah this is going to stand out for the
rest of my life
I remember so this wasn't on the tour
she uh uh this was like my first time in
Europe for a while uh so this was when I
was I went to Cologne for Gamescom yeah
uh so I land there
and there is two cues to get in the
borders one is the EU line and one is
the rest of the world line yeah right
and I'm like last time I came here it
was like post-brexit yeah but they still
allowed us to go to the EU line all
right so I go I go to like the nearest
clerk I'm like I have uh this passport
can I go in the EU line she looks at it
looks at me and just goes
often man
[Music]
we flew from uh Germany to London and um
I I knew that we should just go in the
all other passports like in Europe yeah
um but obviously I mean you look at me
and a lot of people are like no no you
can go and you get on the EU on yeah
this happened in America they think no
no go to the citizens line no no no no
I'm not I'm not no I wish you get the
fast pass a lot a lot of the times yeah
so we were walking and they were like oh
no the EU passport's that way and I show
him our British passport and grants with
me and he goes ugh
he literally said uh
actually looked at the British passport
and I was like what
[Music]
2013 era British people were on top dude
yeah we had a passport game was strong
we were revered now man 10 years later
we are we are bottom of the battle yeah
we're now being British is a downside
[__] a passport's dog [__] it's funny
because like I have I have the opposite
uh every time I re-enter Japan you know
because I look like this
there's the Japan line and then there's
the rest of the world line yeah and I
always just you know without thinking I
just like you start walking up to the
Japanese line always the dude like in
the middle is just like oh excuse me
and I just [__] pulled that [__] out
do you see this every time the guy's
like I'm so sorry even when you're a
foreign
this form every single time you leave I
don't know if you do this in other
countries I've never had a Visa in
another country
um I don't think you do but in Japan
when you leave Japan you have to fill
out a form at the airport saying you're
going to come back to Japan right right
yeah which is so annoying doing this
every single time yeah but even then uh
when I go in that line they'll be like
oh no no tourists this way and I was
like this is literally for foreign
do you see my card yeah
so that's always a little fun a little
just micro complaints you're like it's
just kind of fun to have like to feel
special for a moment yeah yeah I'm
different
to Japan so many times yeah I can I
think I can like do a five minute
accuracy tell you when I'm gonna get out
of the airport because I've done it so
many times if I go now it's a gold split
by the Yeah by the time the plane lands
it's 15 minutes time out of the airport
it's super fast yeah if you get your
bags bags yeah even then you get your
bags so fast in Japan it's crazy totally
it is and you do like the uh Customs
thing online
QR code and then little life hacks you
literally leave the terminal and the
taxi rank is like two seconds away you
go right down the stairs boom get in the
taxi I'm home like 40 minutes I'm like
all right I'm chilling Speed Run it's so
good I love I love airport
is such a good Airport please don't have
a fly into narrator if you can yeah yeah
it's gotten to the point now because
we've uh flown a lot this year for
business that like I've I've noticed
like little things about airports that
I've never noticed before like whenever
we go through security and it's like the
Giga chat [__] security machine you
know the big ones where you do not have
to remove your electronics or any like
liquids I'm like oh this is gonna be a
good experience and then you go to like
the beta little like [__] micro
machines where I I bring like everything
with me you know you know it depends how
beige and gray it looks Yeah the more
Beijing gray it looks the the more [__]
the security is going to be yeah if it
looks really bright and modern it's just
easy yeah like the ones that hunted are
like the huge white machines like a
space portal they're so [__] yeah
yeah those those are the good ones oh do
I have to take my laptop out and it's
like no you don't it's like oh thank God
which one of you were they was that guy
given a hard time at one of the airports
one of you you were getting like grilled
by the guy yeah that was me and Nabi
um
Dublin it was Dublin right yeah Dublin
and then they made you take off your
shoes right yeah they made me take it it
was so weird I was like the I was like
sandwiched in between them and I'm like
we are literally all the same uh yeah
and I'm just chilling I mean I thought I
had a bad because I had to take my shoes
off this guy asked only Joey to take his
shoes off
and then I was like all right that's a
bit weird but whatever did it went
through finals like okay whatever I look
back God is emptying out his gun I'm
just getting the full course like the
full probe yeah this has never happened
to me before but I I took my liquids and
uh my laptops every lecture I've done
this enough times uh and for some reason
uh they're all like oh we need to re-put
your like repo your bag in so I just
thought oh maybe they need to be put
their bag in uh and they asked me to
like empty everything I was like what is
the liquids yeah yeah pour them on the
table they literally like laid it out
like it was a CSI crime Scene you know
and they they took out did they do that
for you as well Navi yeah did they lay
it out like a crime scene I just had on
the tray I just like put it all back in
yeah like exhibit saying I was just like
what is good and I felt so bad because I
saw you two just waiting for me and I'm
like ah guys I know what's going on this
has never happened before uh I'm just
I'm just trying to get through it was
funny yeah yeah sometimes yeah you have
a little bit of privilege
oh yeah I don't know it could have been
anything I don't know but I mean I I
never get stopped I've never been strong
I've never been stopped at an airport
I mean look at me I look I look so basic
uh I also like don't even I'm so bad now
I've gotten to the point where they
always scan my bag anyway because I
bring so many batteries and weird stuff
in yeah I don't even take the laptops
out anymore sometimes I just leave it
all in because they're gonna scan it
anyway I'm scared yeah so I'm like I'll
just leave it all in and then like why'd
you take it out I'm like I forgot and
then they forget about it it's like it's
like two I save time because I don't
want dude it's so annoying I'm gonna
[__] around with four trays and then
everyone's fighting to get in and I'm
like I'm just gonna put all in one yeah
and then I'm gonna deal with the guy and
it's always like the laptop always needs
to be in a separate tray from the bag
and do you ever get those times where
because I take
um a laptop and like a switch and they
don't want them on top of each other and
the tray is almost it's big enough for
one of them but it's just about too
small just to have them both together my
laptop is like here and then the switch
is like kind of leaning on them yeah
yeah yeah yeah now the guys is like no
no no no you can't do it yeah you put it
in a different tray and I'm like oh yeah
yeah I do be like that but uh yeah
honestly literally first world problems
yeah I mean wait listen when you spend
like how many days a year we spent on
the airport you you notice you're like
damn this little efficiencies pissed me
off I genuinely Wonder this year since
we've been doing so much traveling like
if we were to calculated how many days
do you reckon we've been at an airport I
was thinking about this the other day I
was thinking about how much time it's
been flying yeah I think we could easily
calculate it yeah I think I've spent
like at least 10 days in the air this
year at least yeah well the thing I've
seen that the thing that I've kind of
like taken like my mentality has changed
right now is you know there can be some
places like even flying to Europe where
in your mind it's like oh it's just an
hour and a half flight what you don't
really factor in for is the travel time
to the airport how long you have to stay
in the airport how long you have to like
the kind of like the hustle and bustle
getting through customs and everything
like that an hour and a half flight to a
different country turns into like a
four-hour Journey out of your day 25
hours yeah
sorry bullet trains are good yeah yeah
yeah right which is broke up five
minutes before chilling get some coffee
and then you're off in like two hours
yeah yeah so good it's just like travel
days are more than just the time on the
vehicle it's like everything around the
[__] hell today as well you don't
really factor into but if you do it
enough times you're like oh this is a
lot of hours in my life that I'm losing
like traveling I do think when you
travel uh a lot you get this really
weird perspective of travel uh where I
used to think of it as such a huge event
that I was like traveling and then now
I'm like oh no I just I just don't think
about it okay I'll do like a four hour
travel day and I'll be like oh that's
okay yeah I still have I still have
lunch and dinner yeah that's kind of
like the only thing that throws me off
so I can't have like a lunch or dinner
yeah I'm like ah I can't really like
pinpoint where where I'm at in the day
like does it do does the travel time
feel shorter for you yeah like because
like I've done shoots where I've taken
the bullet train to Kyoto yeah and then
come back in the evening and I'm like
that's weird because that's like a
that's like a five hour total Journey
but it doesn't feel that bad when you
kind of it's like spread out and then
you're also so used to traveling and
also you have a you get really good at
finding what to do while traveling I
think that's something yeah like I used
to always download like 500 Netflix
shows and I used to like prepare
everything I was going to watch or what
I was going to read and so what's you go
to now now I just I just I figured out
10 minutes before I get on the plane I'm
like okay I'll download this one Netflix
thing and I'll probably sleep and then
I'll yeah yeah yeah I'll buy the Wi-Fi
and play some chess or like I don't
think about it too much I know you do I
know I constantly have a library of
things that I can watch I I love I love
traveling because it's my one catch up
on stuff yeah yeah it's my one time when
I can just shut off the world I never
buy the online Wi-Fi on my Wi-Fi
I I maybe play a game with my switch or
I watch a movie or watch uh some anime
that I need to catch up on it's great
it's just a time where I can shut up
from the world and just do [__] that I
don't have to feel guilty you know doing
I guess and no one can fault you for it
because you're on a plane yeah yeah
exactly exactly I know I just I just say
oh yeah I'm sorry guys I'm not gonna
reply I'm on a plane yeah but I have
internet I'm just not reading well
sometimes you like it's just like you
don't have the vibe you know also you
know what pissed me off as well that I
found out uh I was like okay the first
time I ever took a like I ever took a
business class flight was like last year
I was super stoked about it and I was
super pumped because I thought like you
see all these videos you're like it
looks so luxurious and I was like oh
hell yeah you pay so much money for it
it's like a ridiculous amount and I was
like oh man I can't I can't wait sit
down like open the Wi-Fi I'm like excuse
me how do I how do I get on the Wi-Fi
trying to make me pay she's like I don't
know you have to pay for the Wi-Fi I was
like what I just what this is like a
five thousand dollar plane seat I had to
pay twenty dollars for the Wi-Fi
[Music]
they still make you pay for Wi-Fi and I
found out it's because it's it's not run
by the plane it's like separately
contracted out it's some [__] weird
thing like that but I was like I was
like it's dumb like dumbass [__] why
should I you already paid an ungodly
amount for like just a chair basically
that's slightly bigger what the [__] a
chair that's slightly bigger okay camera
climb yeah you can turn into a bed yeah
it's the game changer exactly that
doesn't mean they'll just make a 12-hour
flight easier oh my God totally yeah I
mean would you guys
I don't know are you guys thinking about
traveling as much next year because we
did a lot this year I mean I say no but
I will yeah that's kind of what I
figured out because like you know last
year I said the exact same thing about
2023 I was like damn I did so much
travel in 2022. 2023 is going to be the
chill year
turns out I've traveled more this year
than I think I have in my entire life I
think I only feel like I've really
traveled like a big amount if it's
longer than a week if it's less than a
week I don't think about it much oh my
God it's chill that's true yeah if it's
over than a week it's kind of a big deal
yeah I think I think that's what I want
to do more next year is just kind of
like non-work related short travel you
know maybe like uh less than a week type
of travel just because I want to go
somewhere you know like I still want to
explore like a ton of like Southeast
Asian countries because I just feel like
it's a waste to not go there living in
Asia you know yeah yeah so I want to do
more of that next year with Aki and like
yeah I don't know but again we say all
this it's probably going to be more
traveling next year
I mean I mean traveling to America is a
must for work exactly I want to travel
more for Holiday yeah I want to I want
to take I want to take more holiday next
year totally yeah this has been uh great
that's why October November for me I'm
[__] staying in Japan I'm not I'm not
going anywhere I say that but I'm gonna
all you know
so you're not so it's still Japan
technically yeah yeah yeah yeah just
just three hours just a three hour
flight